today on stick to football connor and i
are hanging out at radio row in
beautiful miami beach florida it is a
lot hotter than i expected it's nice man
i ran out of the northeast to get back
down here
oh my god go home back home for two days
i know you didn't get to go home no and
then ran back down here and we're
excited to be here at radio road because
obviously matt we're gonna have a busy
week very busy week we're gonna have a
lot of interviews and we apologize for
the show schedule being a little funky
this week but uh you'll get your mock
draft today that you expected on monday
you get it on tuesday or wednesday
morning whenever you're listening to
this but a lot of great interviews and
then our event saturday february 1st at
1 p.m here in miami with special guest
kenny vaccaro going to stop by we get to
talk to him about how hard it is to
tackle derek henry
if texas is back a secret about kenny he
will text me like breakdowns on players
like his goal is to have my job when he
retires from the nfl and so we might
have to throw some blows you're giving
him the platform saturday you're right
it's an audition just an audition for
the job so if you are in the miami area
or if you just want to drive over from
wherever you are we're going to be at
1111 lincoln road that is the bleacher
report venue there's a lot of stuff
going on there this week and our show
will be at one o'clock from one to two
on saturday mello will be in town with
us kenny vaccaro will be joining us they
had a great season too so it's a really
good time to have kenny on the show i
think and yeah but before we even get to
saturday there's going to be a lot going
on here tons of different players
including draft prospects are going to
stop by and talk to me and matt so
basically the next month i think you
guys are going to have at least one
interview almost every single show yeah
and some of them are going to be from
from here so if we ask them some dated
questions uh you'll understand why
and then we should throw out there
saturday night we're actually going to
be that's right it's a big it's crazy
excuse me uh we're going to be going to
fort lauderdale downtown fort lauderdale
some of our friends from kansas city
have somehow procured 25 different bars
they're shutting down three city blocks
and we are co-hosting it alongside guys
like donta hall tom bahali whitmer field
so some casey legends and then us
so i know that there's a hundred dollar
like vip thing if you want it but
otherwise it's free you can just come in
hang out um the hundred dollars i think
gets you like free drinks and free food
you don't have to pay that just come
hang out we will be there uh we'll have
more details to post on twitter but
let's get into this mock draft man
because today
not just one round we're gonna do two
rounds surprise yeah you're welcome uh
no we felt bad that we didn't do the
show that came out monday morning so
this is our uh our makeup to you guys so
let's jump into it and a lot of these
picks it's just routine for us so it's a
little bit more fun to stretch our legs
and get into two rounds but it starts
here cincinnati bengals number one
overall i don't see any way they're
trading out of this pick i don't see any
way they're drafting anyone other than
this guy joe burrow and something that
i've noticed as we we're past senior
bowl now doing a lot of the evaluation
of this class is that when you look at
the quarterback position especially
there's joe burrow and then for me
there's everyone else because there are
questions about health with tua there's
questions on the field with justin
herbert questions on the field of jordan
love
whoever you want to put in there jake
from jacob easton i have questions about
all those guys with joe burrow it's just
like can he keep up at this rate that we
saw this past year and i've even gotten
some messages on instagram from some
bengals fans and they're sitting there
and they're going hey you know what is
the package like if we even think about
trading out of this pick and i'm like
you don't have to think about it because
from everything we've gathered they're
set on joe burrow they're comfortable
with making him the future face of the
franchise there so i think when you look
at it for cincinnati matt that's a
really really easy pick and i'm going to
jump right into number two here which i
think is also an easy pick because this
guy's still my number one player on my
big board and that's chase young for the
washington redskins i think when you
look at chase i've seen some questions
written up about well why wasn't he
productive against michigan and clemson
and i'm like well go watch the tape
because sure the sax might not be in the
box score but when you look at what
chase did creating pressure drawing
double teams right he did a lot of
things that don't show up in the box
score so i think for washington you
traded up and you got montes sweat last
year right there's a foundation on that
defensive line of really really good
players a lot of them from the sec
and i think when you look at adding
chase it's almost like adding that last
piece in a very long puzzle i know
there's been some dysfunction with
washington over the years but i actually
think ron rivera is walking into a
situation where this football team is
going to have an identity very soon and
a lot of that identity will evolve
around a future double-digit sack player
in chase young i mean you could look at
a team that we're down here miami to
evaluate in san francisco they have five
first rounders along that defensive line
uh this is very similar to that because
you would have four montes sweat uh
drawn payne you would have john allen
now you add in chase young you go with
matt knight who's really good too and
you can start to build an identity there
number three overall we've said before
this is really where the draft starts it
will be interesting to see if detroit
trades out of this spot depending on the
health of tuatang of ioloa depending on
the evaluation of justin herbert we're
not doing trades at least not yet in
mock drafts how many of them jeff akuda
this is just easy he's the next best
player on the board he is a shutdown
corner in a year without chase young i
think we would talk a lot more about
akuda because he is one of the best
corners that i've had the pleasure of
evaluating in the last 10 years it's
crazy he doesn't even get hype on his
own team because of jay jung because of
justin fields and jk dobbins but man
jeff akuta is incredibly special the
lions need help in the secondary this is
an easy addition i think so too i think
when you look at akuda it's funny to me
because he's somebody that we've just
penciled him into the top five picks for
so long and we almost barely talk about
him i know the national media does not
talk about him and then five years from
now
i believe he'll be a top five corner in
the nfl i really do it wouldn't shock me
if he's a top three corner in nfl that's
how good he is it's almost the prototype
when you look at the length size speed
physicality the ability to play the ball
in the air so number four this is the
new york giants now matt this pick has
to be an offensive tackle to me i think
it's non-negotiable at this point i
think when you look at how the board has
fallen the giants are not taking a
quarterback you know maybe a team
it's going to be interesting with the
giants to see if somebody moves up to
this pick for a quarterback now dave
gettleman has never traded a first round
pick so do they even consider that if
they don't this pick is very simple for
me it's jedrick wills from alabama he's
the best offensive tackle i've seen i
know for a while for me i was andrew
thomas i think will's passed him this
year he's a little more athletic than
andrew thomas he just is honestly a
little bit nastier of a player both very
good players but i think for the giants
this is the best possible option you
need to protect your young franchise
quarterback that had some fumbling
issues this year one way to mitigate
that is make sure it doesn't get hit
yeah and help sacramento barclay please
course
so i definitely think that's a smart
pick and wills is my top tackle and
there's been a lot of hype out there for
other guys will's is my number one
change probably not gonna change number
five the miami dolphins we are in their
hometown let's make people happy here it
is nice here tua's gonna love it when
he's the pig at number five overall it's
warm it's probably going to remind him
of home back in hawaii because it is man
it's beautiful here and he is the
perfect fit for them we talked all
summer about tanking for tua tang for
tua they acquired a ton of draft picks
just in case they needed to trade up for
this player now they don't have to
because of the hip injury the questions
surrounding him and the way the draft
order panned out the redskins don't need
a quarterback the lions don't need a
quarterback the giants don't need a
quarterback two falls perfectly into
their lap now this could be a thing
we're on draft day you have to trade up
to number three to make sure no one else
jumps you whether that's the chargers
panthers whomever else but in this spot
i think two it makes the most sense i
think so too and number six for the
chargers once again this is the time of
year for mock drafts where we're not
really introducing players in the first
round anymore you've heard about these
guys you've heard of what we think about
them we're trying to predict what's
going to happen and if i'm doing that at
number six for the chargers matt i think
this pick is justin herbert i really do
now do the chargers make some kind of
power play for a free agent quarterback
or do they make a power play up to three
to take a player like tua those things
remain to be seen are they comfortable
with making tyrod taylor a bridge
quarterback for you know somebody that
they wait longer on if i'm a betting man
i still think it's going to be justin
herbert especially if he's just sitting
there in the six spot there's also a
really good place for him to go develop
it really is a good place for him to
develop tyrod taylor's probably going to
be there for a year we've heard jay
glaser's report that they're moving on
rivers and we heard that at the senior
board heard it a lot there too so um
this is a team that needs a quarterback
depending on how you feel about tyrod
taylor or a guy like teddy bridgewater
and free agency there's some dominoes
left to fall brady that one makes the
most okay i get asked that a lot i can't
see tom playing behind that offensive
line it's a weird fit and like i mean
they come from a personal standpoint
it's a really weird fit and i think a
lot of people just want him to like go
back to california they want the
chargers to sell tickets well the league
needs it more than right the league
definitely needs it they might need him
in vegas as a raider at number seven
overall the carolina panthers another
team that has a decision to make at
quarterback with cam newton his contract
kind of being a mess he's been hurt the
last year and a half new owner new head
coach we really don't know yet what
direction they're gonna go as far as
quarterback goes so i'm gonna give them
a huge upgrade on the offensive line
instead last year we saw them make moves
on the o-line to really secure or
hopefully secure the future they trade
up and draft greg little well this year
i'm gonna give them a little bit more
help on the offensive line with makai
bechten who our friend daniel jeremiah i
think shocked the draft world when he
put this dude at four overall and i was
having a conversation with you today um
about bechden what exactly what i told
you was i'll be honest i didn't think he
was gonna declare so i didn't watch him
all season outside of like seeing him
play other people
and then when he declared it was
basically senior bowl time she was like
i'm going to get to him after the senior
bowl then dj drops the bomb on everybody
of like number four overall and i spent
friday thursday and friday in mobile i
spent those talking to duke manny
weather who is the best offensive line
coach in the game exactly and he's
working with bechten so i spent a lot of
time talking to duke about here were the
concerns i saw on tape you know he
doesn't come to balance well is he too
big which it can be a concern so i feel
better about bechten now that i've had a
chance to talk to duke now that i've had
additional game tape sent to me that i
was able to break down so becked in at
seven
two weeks ago i would have said that's
pretty rich like i could see it but
that's pretty rich now we're in a
position where it it really feels like
he's a lock in the top ten because of
all the teams that need offensive
tackles and i think you make a great
point about the panthers this is a team
that does not have to take a quarterback
this year those guys that rule it's a
gigantic contract they don't need to
rush into this uh it doesn't seem like
they've been super proactive about
moving on from cam newton yet where
they're in a rush to do that so maybe
they see what he has left in the tank
that's you know very up in the they
could go so many directions because they
could take isaiah simmons you know luke
keagley retires they could go they could
go corner here with cj henderson they
could go a million different directions
i would argue they're one of the bigger
x factors in the top ten number eight
the cardinals i think this is another
team that can go in a lot of different
directions but i'm gonna go with jerry
judy here for them larry fitzgerald is
obviously getting up there in age this
might be his last season
you know david johnson was their best
skill player and he just has not been
healthy matt that contract is not
looking good they need somebody
explosive with the football now i do
think they have talent there but judy is
kind of when they took larry fitzgerald
a lot of people looked at that pick and
said okay this is going to be our
identity at wide receiver probably 10
years if it works out really well it did
yeah judy feels like the same thing to
me again
you take him and you go we're probably
going to have our number one wide
receiver for the next 10 years i think
cliff kingsbury looks at him differently
than a lot of these other teams in the
top 10 and will value that yeah he's not
going to look at him still he's not very
big yep say okay we'll look out faster
right i feel like with judy we've just
over evaluated him because two years and
it's i mean i remember talking about uh
nick and joey boasted this way where
it's like can the draft just get here
because yeah we're looking for problems
at this point and i think we're going to
scare it that year it absolutely did i
remember people saying that he had no
production
and it's just like come on but i you
know what i i think i was telling this
story in mobile people who used to get
on me because in the 2017 draft there
was michael thomas from ohio state and
then there was mike thomas from like
southern miss yeah that was the rams
people used to always be like do you
mean the good mike thomas referring to
the southern miss guy or the bad michael
thomas friend of ohio state and i would
just lose my [ __ ] well they need to
reveal themselves yeah right i'm sure
the tweets exist number nine overall the
jacksonville jaguars another team that
could go a lot of directions kelvin
smith has walked away from football
might never come back uh they could go
almost any position honestly they could
go receiver here the only thing they
probably shouldn't do is draft a running
back in the top ten now i have them
taking tristan worfs at offensive tackle
i think tristan worth is really unique
because he's played right tackle at iowa
he could play guard i think he could be
like a zack martin type guard but he can
also play left tackle when you look at
the jag's offensive line cam robinson
hasn't been terrible but he hasn't been
great so you could either move on from
him or move him inside andrew norwell's
huge contract but hasn't lived up to it
i see his offensive line it's not
terrible but they need an infusion of
talent and worfs can help just get your
best five on the field and he is such a
good run blocker at the second level of
the field i think when you look at the
jacksonville offense this year
he's kind of a plug and play fit that
when the team goes up in offensive
production and running the football
you're gonna sit there and well how did
that happen then you go back to the
wharfs pick and go well that's an
instant impact kind of player so number
10 the cleveland browns they're another
team that has to go offensive line in
this spot so this will be our fourth
offensive tackle going in the top ten
that's very impressive and it's gonna be
andrew thomas plug and play player for
cleveland listen baker mayfield did not
look very good this year i think some of
that was on the offensive line he was
drifting out of the pocket a lot it felt
like so when you look at the browns they
just need to really upgrade this unit as
a whole thomas played left tackle at
georgia this year i think he can
actually similarly to works he could
play right tackle he can play guard this
is adding a piece for the browns and you
got to get these guys while you can
because as the jets are on the clock
next they learned that all four
offensive tackles that are up on the
board are gone exactly i was gonna say
it's four tackles in the top ten it's
the worst possible notes for the new
york jets which makes me think this is a
team that could be very active on draft
day as far as trying to trade up trying
to acquire more picks because or a
higher pick excuse me because of this
huge need at offensive tackle again with
no trades we got to shake things up do
something different i'm going caleb on
chase i like that a lot they need an
edge rusher if you can't get an
offensive tackle here get an edge rusher
try to build your line through you know
second round pigs try to build it
through free agency
what they didn't get the previous regime
was allergic to drafting edge rushers it
seemed like and then the one they
drafted ended up being a turd and i kind
of polite so i think this way you're
going with a guy who he got to rock the
18 at lsu that means you're a high
character player it means that the
people in the program believe in you
that the alumni believe in you i think
with chase on yes you're getting a guy
who didn't have a ton of production at
college but you're also getting someone
who
teams ran away from they schemed away
from him he ran against a lot of teams
that were running option and rpo and
they played off of him but also i think
the sky's the limit he was a redshirt
sophomore he's still a young player with
a lot of room ahead of him to develop
and if you have questions about chase on
when you look at the production go back
to the film this is somebody that
absolutely dusted both alex leatherwood
and isaiah wilson on georgia so when you
look at that those are two offensive
tackles that are pretty good players and
he torched them whether it was the spin
move whether it was an outside rush with
bend i think json does a lot of things
really nice and that is getting away
you're right matt from what the jets
usually do because the last regime did
not draft one athletic edge guy polite
did not test well right you know when
you look at jordan jenkins he's been a
nice player but he's more of an
edge-setting effort sack kind of player
so they need to get more athletic at
that spot json's a really nice pick 12
to las vegas raiders i'm going with
isaiah simmons here this is probably the
easiest pick off to make in round one
can't believe he's still here it's you
say that and you go well yeah it's
shocking but at the same time we've seen
very good off-ball linebackers fall this
far over and over again now simmons can
play safety you can rush the passer you
can play weak side linebacker inside
linebacker he can really do everything
but with the offensive line rush the
quarterback rush akuda has to be in the
mix there i think the raiders and
raiders fans will love hearing this
actually have a shot at getting simmons
at 12. i believe it because we have
three quarterbacks going in the top ten
at four offensive tackles that's great
news for the for the las vegas raiders
if that happens at number 13 the
indianapolis colts just mentioned it we
saw three quarterbacks fly off the board
well i firmly i would have told you two
months ago no i think they just stick
with brissett jacobi per se like they'll
roll with him next year i don't know if
they do and even if they do they're
gonna have to plan for the future i
think chris ballard takes one look at
jordan loves game film and his profile
and says hey kind of reminds me of that
kid they drafted in kansas city now i'm
not saying they're the same but their
traits are very very similar and i think
with jordan love you just worry about
the decision making go to 2018 looked
really good go to 2019 it looked really
bad so i feel like this guy who was
pressing at times and had an okay senior
bowl week i think justin herbert really
outshined him there but he was fine but
a good week a good week so i do believe
jordan love when i saw sin done is give
me a top 15 pick and i think it makes
sense like you said matt even a poor
man's patmo homes is a really really
good player right and also
brissett's actually the kind of player
that
wouldn't like philip rivers this and be
like well i'm not playing where you
drafted my replacement he'll just you
know so
i think when you look at it the colts
can really do this they can sit love for
the entire year if they need to then
presets contracts up and then love
becomes the starters so colts fans
you're gonna have to be a little patient
if that's the pick right but sometimes
that works for the better all right
moving on 14 to the tampa bay bucks this
will surprise people but this pick would
not surprise me i have jacob eason here
at 14. i think the bucks will grade out
guys like herbert love they'll have them
higher rated than eason if they're gonna
sit and wait here there's a good chance
they don't get the chance to draft those
guys right i think bruce arians will
look at easton's skill set and go hey i
can get that guy to really excel in my
offense throwing the football down the
field and not turn the ball over 30
times like jameis winstead eason will
have his turnover issues but i think he
has a higher ceiling right now than
jameis does going forward where and also
kind of have this feeling and correct me
if you feel differently matt i just
think bruce ariens feels comfortable
with or without jameis winston in the
future
yeah i don't think it's make or break
that he's back right i don't either and
and i think with aryans like you said
he's so scheme specific as far as what
he wants you need a downfield threat but
you have to it's like you're not even
considering jake from here you know it's
not a possibility the good news is and
like tua is not a good fit in this
offense either but herbert love and
easton are all three fit so if one of
those guys is on the board i think it
would be really really interesting to
see which route they go because they
need help on defense as well number 15
the denver broncos maybe a surprise here
but cd lam is still on the board and
that is a travesty so i'm taking him
comparable cortland sutton
and now you have an offense that jor
that drew lock almost called him jordan
love same guy the drew lock can just
really unload in and they can keep this
building when you hire pat shermer you
know you want big plays cd's going to
give you those shermer actually has done
a really good job with young receivers
too you look at what darius slayton did
with the giants i actually really like
i know shermer was not a popular head
coach and he made a lot of bad decisions
i like him as an offensive coordinator a
lot for not only drew lock but for the
skill talent that they'll have in there
last pick before we take a quick break
here of the first half of the first
round the atlanta falcons you might not
even realize it but guess who's still on
the board and he's going to be playing
next to grady jarrett that's derek brown
from auburn
it's wild now i'm not saying derek brown
not going to the senior bowl tank to
stock or anything like that but it's
just that some of the buzz cools i still
think derrick brown is probably a top
seven player in this class but he's a
defensive tackle where other positions
are being prioritized he'll be great for
atlanta that is a dynamite duo upfront
on the defensive line and really good
value for atlanta but you can see him
falling outside the top 15 if the board
breaks this way and that's why we do
these because it is a picture of what
could happen now he could also go third
overall sure you know and and so that
makes it tough because guys do fall and
and you're going to look at back this in
april be like well that one team stops
the fall and it is it makes you wonder
how much farther a guy like a derrick
brown if the lions don't take him or the
jags don't take him how far does he get
perfect example oj howard the jets
thought about it at six thought about it
long and hard yep they didn't take him
they took jamal adams he fell outside
the top 15. it happens a lot more than
you'd expect yup absolutely does let's
take a break we come back the dallas
cowboys are on the clock
number 17 overall conor the dallas
cowboys are on the clock this is a team
that will be so reshaped by free agency
i don't even know where to go but i feel
confident that byron jones won't be back
so we can look at corner here cj
henderson is cemented as my number two
corner in this class he's feisty he's
not a physical tackler but he's a
physical cover man i think he has the
size the speed the instincts that we're
looking for to be a true number one
corner and that's something dallas i
don't even think byron jones was ever
that so dallas has a big need here yeah
jones is more of an athletic kind of
player so it's gonna be interesting to
see if he leaves in free agency matt and
also at 17 even if jones is back you
have to wonder if dallas just loads up a
corner as well with how this board is
broken
it's not like derek brown is there maybe
javon kinlaw would be somebody they
consider here instead number eighteen
the miami dolphins are back on the clock
they already got their franchise
quarterback and tuatanga vailoa now they
go with aj panesa you're seeing a theme
with this mock draft the rise of
offensive tackles and quarterbacks is
pushing very highly rated players down
the board especially on the defensive
side of the ball it's crazy right miami
needs an edge presence under brian
flores he knows that brian flores is a
really nice fit i mean this is like trey
flowers yes evanescent can be his
straight flowers uh dietrich wise it
fits the mold of guys we've seen the
patriots draft and if flores is going to
run that same scheme then go get those
same type of yeah i feel really good
about that pick at 18. yeah 19 the
raiders are on the clock again this is
the pick they got from the chicago bears
you gave them a linebacker at number 12
overall and isaiah simmons we couldn't
believe he was still available i'm going
to give him a speed receiver at 19 and
i'm kind of surprised he's available
henry rugs the third from alabama he and
his 4-2 speed are on the board here i
was talking to some people last week
from from exos which is like the biggest
training facility uh pre-combine
trainers and they i don't believe henry
ruggs is working with them but it was
funny because we were sitting in the
stands in mobile and he was like do you
think he breaks the record and he's like
man it'll be close and what's what we
were laughing about is that we're even
having this conversation yes he could
break the record it's amazing the record
with an asterisk on it because i still
don't see that john ross broke it's cj
2k's record absolutely is didn't they do
the holograms that doesn't matter cj
wins
come on rugs in this offense could
stretch the field he can give them what
ab was supposed to be someone who will
stretch the field open things up for
their really good tight end duo open
things up for josh jacob so field
stretcher here who i mean he can be your
tyree kill type of offensive threat if
that duo happens for the raiders on
draft night i will personally give their
draft an eight-plus like i might be a
raiders isaiah
i don't need people jumping on me brady
goes there you'll be ready then i can be
so my oldest brother's a raiders fan and
sometimes like sand and mock drafts and
just like look what could happen like
look what could happen your life can be
really good in the death star in vegas
right 20 jacksonville they're back on
the clock again we obviously helped out
their offensive line in the top ten but
now we're going to go on the other side
of the ball matt and i were talking
before the show this might seem like a
rise for this player but i have patrick
queen here
i think he's so good when you look at
that table especially at the end of the
year telvin smith status we don't know
anything and when you don't know
anything you don't expect anything
i don't think there's been contact
between him and the team since he left
which should tell you everything who
knows because tom coughlin was the
problem and he's gone sure but you do
worry i just i love this player him and
miles jack flying around yeah now a big
thing that matters here matt is what is
going to happen wooden gaque on the edge
are they going to be able to get a
contract done with him are they going to
trade him for more picks but at the end
of the day i just look at this
linebacker duo between queen and miles
jack and that's speed and it works in
the end so let's just get crazy let's
just get it out you know i love patrick
queen and that's why everybody's like oh
this player is a rise for you and i
believe i've told this story on the
podcast before that when i was talking
to people at lsu about who was coming
out and they sent you the laundry list
and they were like he got it go back to
school grade why do you keep like why do
you keep asking about him i was like
he's my like favorite player that you
have outside of you know some of the
guys that like joe burrow and if there
was this weird back and forth to where
they were like you know can you stop
talking we don't want this yeah
like i have to be honest and tell you
guys the players i like and and when i
when he declared you know i put out my
early grade on him before i really
stacked players was top 40. like i
thought he was round one but worst case
scenario early round two and then like
you said the more you watch the more you
just fall in love with his athleticism
he's a really good player number 21 the
philadelphia eagles this is such an
obvious thing it's just which receivers
on the board that's who they're going to
take i'm going to give them justin
jefferson here henry ruggs would have
been my my priority pick for them but
when you compare him we don't i don't
know what the hell is going on with j.j
our psycho white side why he can't get
on the field really bad receiver depth
chart once some people got hurt justin
jefferson gives them youth which they so
desperately need he is one of the
cleanest route runners that i've seen i
mean he reminds me of keenan allen but
my ultimate con for him was davonte
adams but the route running is just so
so clean he's a great route runner it
fits their system alshon jeffrey's
contract is you know going to be a
little bit of a problem but they know
they have to add to that that wide
receiver group now it's a team that's
actively tried to trade for robbie
anderson in the past i think if we if we
see them sign him then you know it's a
howie move if we see them not show
interest at all then it's very
interesting to see so the eagles wide
receiver that's an easy easy match it's
like with miles sanders last year
running back right we knew they were
going to take him for how long and then
when it happens do i go up no surprise
anticlimactic 22 same thing buffalo
bills they need a big body wide receiver
this guy's the best on the board that i
have in that group that's t higgins from
cleveland they would be so happy if this
happened i know i actually can see them
getting aggressive in this stream i
wanted to ask brandon b yes last week a
couple times oh hey like what do you
think of t higgins just like real just
put it out
yeah out of nowhere i think the bills
are a team that has to really consider
they can they're patient as you've seen
in their docu series with the cody ford
situation last year they won't do
anything stupid or crazy or emotional
but i think they'll be monitoring that
board matt and if there's a run earlier
on wide receivers than they expect the
bills might have to make a phone call at
some point yeah they might and we've
seen them do that before like brandon
said you know they've been aggressive
they've drafted very well number 23 the
nemesis of all of us basically the new
england patriots they could go a billion
directions this is terrifying honestly
they could draft any position and we
would be like okay jake from kind of get
it
wouldn't be surprised you know what i i
liked your student but i wouldn't be
surprised so i have them doing the most
belichick thing ever and taking javon
kinlow it's an easy because like i think
he's going to look at javon kenlon have
visions of richard seymour and what he
can be to a defensive line he could play
five tech he could play inside he could
do everything for you could wreck the
game could in a big way and we know that
belichick values the trenches now again
they could go
every direction yeah that's no idea what
they're gonna do but if i was a betting
man with ken law all the way at 23
that's the pick i would make as well so
for new england that's a huge ad 24 the
new orleans saints
i know we've talked about it a lot and
their fans have been vocal about it that
this team needs a number two wide
receiver
i think they can if they can't find that
in free agency you could find that later
in this draft i'm gonna go corner here
with christian fulton and i know
fulton's film has been up and down for
people at times he played hurt this year
i think when you go back to fulton's
junior year film when we got to see him
against georgia in person but just
overall he's a great player i like him
more than greedy williams coming out and
i just think for the saints getting that
number two corner and maybe they make
another run for it again next year yeah
i i think the saints are really hard to
predict because i mean we've heard
reports uh jay glaser said that they
won't take some hill long term now not
teddy bridgewater and
what is this offense going to look like
if it's taysom hill is it going to be
like baltimore where they just go all in
on the run game so this could be i mean
who knows this could be jk dobbins here
for all we know so there are a lot of
directions they could go but corner is
the safe bet for sure number 25 the
minnesota vikings another team that this
could be jake from they can start to
think about quarterback in the future
with kirk cousins only under contract
for one more year but i'm gonna go with
corner here because i do feel like they
have to think there's an obvious window
here of success with the talent we've
seen them have so jeff gladney from tcu
another player who might feel like a
riser but i'm just such a big fan of his
he's i've said before this year's
rockies in for me a player that i just
you fall in love with and then it's so
much fun to watch them rise throughout
the process once everyone else gets
around to watching the tape so i'm a big
jeff gladney guy he's physical he's
tough and i think he fits exactly what
they need in minnesota somehow xavier
rhodes made the pro bowl though so the
pro bowl is right he's a laugher and i
think for gladney he's going to run sub
4-4 that kind of speed with his cover
ability the nfl teams in the first round
are just they're going to be all over
that especially after this corner run so
good timing for the vikings 26 the miami
dolphins this pick is from the laramie
tunzel trade and they're going to use it
on a future offensive lineman that's
josh jones from houston
really you know great length from josh
jones i think he's had a really good
start to this draft process as a whole i
think the more and more people dive into
him
you're gonna hear that early second
round that late first round because now
that beckton has risen all the way into
the top 15 top ten the tier two guys
tier three guys are gonna bump up a
little bit as well so for miami they
need help on this offensive line
especially if you're bringing a guy that
is a little injury prone in there and
tuatunga by lowe yeah yeah you got to
protect him jones is so athletic we were
up in our suite watching practices last
week i think it was tuesday when i was
like guys he's andre dillard like yeah i
mean they might be the same player andre
diller just went to a bigger school so
we knew a little bit more about him
light feed coming into the process
absolutely number 27 the seattle
seahawks this is a hard team to pick for
i wanted to go edge rusher here but
there were none on the board that i felt
were of value so i'm going to give them
a player who can do a little bit of
everything on the d-line that's marlon
davidson who went to mobile tuesday had
one of the best practices i've seen for
defensive linemen since aaron donald was
there just wrecking the hopes and dreams
of offensive linemen
the dude's legit he's around one player
he played as a five technique uh for
auburn he could play inside he could do
a little bit of everything he has the
squarest body i think i've ever seen
though
like straight down and he had the biker
shorts on i liked it it was a really
good showing for marlin davidson it was
similar how nathan shepard came down
from one practice where he fractured his
hand beat everybody in front of him yeah
like
all right moving on to the nfl draft so
yeah great for davidson 28 the baltimore
ravens very easy pick you probably heard
this pick since september or october now
kenneth murray at linebacker you know
they lost cj mosley last year this team
has done a really nice job replacing
players in the front seven they're going
to lose matt judon and free agency i
know they've or they're going to trade
him
oh can they they could franchise and
very interesting to do and judon's had a
really good year but i also understand
that baltimore they just can't pony up
that kind of cash especially a position
they replace over and over again murray
has great speed he's a playmaker i think
he can go sideline to sideline for them
and also i think he's really good as a
blitzer so you are getting some pass
rush help there with canada kenneth
murray so for the ravens there i don't
know how they do it
but they always get these great players
no matter where they pick in the draft
matt jude on sneaky old he's 28 years
that's what i was going to say because
he managed 24 he was an older udfa as a
college free agent oh man that sucks
well get one more contract buddy 29 the
tennessee titans sometimes we have them
taking a running back here not today i'm
going to address the d line i think when
you looked at where they fell short in
the playoffs it was their inability to
stop people yes and we'll see what
happens with free agency ryan
tannehill's a free agent derek henry's a
free agent we know all about that jack
conklin's a free agent but i think
they're going to have to bolster the d
line ross blacklock from tcu maybe
hasn't received the hype that he should
but his quickness is amazing the only
question is there there's some injury
history that has to be checked out but i
can remember arya scouts going through
there in like october saying this is a
second round player who if he continues
to play the way he is probably a first
round player he had a great year and
he's a very good athlete at d-line i was
going to say this is the first time he's
made it into the first round on the
stick to football mock draft so it's
always fun when we introduce these
players on the back end of round one
all right number 30 the green bay
packers you know this team needs a wide
receiver i'm going with leviska chanal i
think when you look at the thing chanel
can do he can win down the field
vertically he can return punts and kicks
if you need him too they've used them on
jet sweeps they've used them in the
direct snap wildcat
just get them the [ __ ] football so
for green bay davonte adams libiscus
chanel
people i feel like people are looking we
don't fit in here no um
but we're not we
people on youtube can see what's
happening they're gonna have to pull
connor's dead cold fingers from this
table to get us
right uh somebody needs to do the wolf
of wall street gif right now all right
31 kansas city chiefs not a prediction
this is just based on win losses not a
prediction don't get on me number 31 the
kansas city chiefs they have to go
corner here uh we've said it a million
times only have two guys under contract
next year every shot fentanyl in your
various wards gotta go corner aj terrell
gives them size i know we got roughed up
the national championship game i went
back and watched that game
this past weekend while i had a little
downtime he was owning everybody in the
first quarter yes then they started
going at him a little bit more i still
think he's a good player who just had a
bad game he should be a first-rounder
and also if you're looking at who's
beating him it's jamar chase the only
person who beat him all year you've
called the next julio jones so put it on
the level if julio jones beats your
favorite player in the nfl you
can't
go
anything about it all right 32 the 40
diners who are apparently expected to
win the super bowl here the way this
mock trap is ordered xavier mckinney
we've had this pick a lot i know some
people are going to turn their heads and
go wow mckinney over delphi i just think
he's a safer pick right now it pains me
to say i loved grant delbit before this
year but the film overall forget being
bumpy it's just bad a lot this year matt
yeah just and he liked the tweet that i
said i didn't have him in the first
round and he liked it and i'm like man
i'm sorry but give a little more effort
on the field and a little less effort on
twitter and you might be in the first
round
i know i know it's not a great and he
doesn't fit what the niners need anyway
i agree and i think mckinney once again
i know we run this thing into the ground
but he is plug and play for a team that
doesn't have a lot of needs not many no
and not many free agents to worry about
either exactly so for the 49ers the the
future is looking bright i mean like the
super bowl curse always happens super
loser it's always a hangover it wouldn't
be crazy if these two teams are back
here next i wouldn't be shocked at all i
mean the chiefs can be the patriots in
the next 10 years where it's like every
other year or more you're like oh
[ __ ] chiefs and the niners might have
the best head coach in football not
named bill belichick i would agree and a
good staff which isn't getting poached
yet it's amazing so no they're all
together for another daniel salad
they're all staying so for the niners
even if you lose this weekend put a
smile on that face yeah that'll be me
next week yeah trying to you know
put a silver lining on all right we'll
take a break we come back round two of
the mock draft we're finally going two
rounds on this baby be back right after
this
we are back on street football round two
for the first time all draft season i'm
riding a seven round mock draft
currently and i'm about six rounds in
and i got mad at it and deleted a whole
whole thing the whole thing this morning
i was like you know what i don't like it
anymore
erased it i was having some fun with
twitter saying i found the espresso
machine and i was going to do a
seven-round mock trap i was lying don't
do it i was getting ready for our
two-rounder which is very different on a
podcast it is because me and matt do it
together there's a lot of back and forth
a lot of explanations yeah and you'll
make picks that i wouldn't have things
like that totally so let's get right one
that comes out monday will be a lot
different than this the bengals at 33 i
think they need another wide receiver aj
green's a free agent we don't know if
he'll be back brandon nyuk is my guy
pair him with tyler boyd ayuk speed his
playmaker ability in the open field i
wouldn't be shocked that he's a first
rounder by late april this opinion might
change i think the hype for ayuka has
gotten a little out of control i think
so too because we got to mobile and
everyone was saying because this is
before he was medically not cleared to
practice like oh he's going to be a top
25 player by the end of the week he
doesn't practice so that hurts i think
with mobile i've been doing this long
enough to i've even guilty of this at
times too there's a bias to guys you see
of course and i was i was talking to a
big country about this after you all
left town that a lot of times you see a
guy and you fall in love with them and
then you remember that there are six or
seven juniors better than them at their
position and so it's like once you stack
in judy lamb rug chanel higgins and
jefferson
ayuk's the seventh receiver at best and
it's hard to go top 25 that way 34 the
colts man must be nice to have this pick
after trading with washington last year
this is a great spot for the colts and
they get a player that i have in round
one and that's guitor gross mottos so
they've taken some swings at edge over
the years i don't think a lot of them
have worked out keep on swinging baby if
you're the colts you need a pass rush up
front they signed justin houston last
year well you know turret has been hurt
a lot so once again this is a team that
needs a pass rush for the future and
gross mottos is an ascending player a
younger player you're actually going to
hear from him on this show pretty soon
because we're going to sit down and have
a talk with him so we're excited for
that and for the colts this is just
really good value good tell me how to
say his name finally yeah
get to the bottom of this i've heard it
too many ways number 35 the detroit
lions we had them going corner at three
overall let's just keep in the in the
second area here i'm gonna give them
grant delpit you know we've seen the
problems they've had in the secondary
they trade quandary digs he becomes a
pro bowler and they just they have
that's still bizarre and it is you trade
a leader in one of your best players and
he becomes a pro bowler now i mean i
like dairy slay but he is getting older
i like justin coleman just fine but i
don't know that he is the elite outside
player and then you look at the safety
position tavon wilson and tracy walker
i'm not really excited about either of
those players i know they drafted will
harris in the third round last year he
hasn't broken into the starting lineup
yet so i look at grant dell but he can
be he's gonna push one of those guys to
a third safety spot but he can come play
in the box he can rush off the edge he
can do a lot of special things the
question is just are you going to get
the effort that we saw from him in 2018
or the effort that we saw in 2019
because they are very different stories
that's the toughest part when you look
at grant delpit i think when it comes
down to it which player are you getting
now i hope you know for the sake of the
cowboys there you get the guy that was
for the lions there you get the guy that
was phenomenal as an underclassman as a
sophomore even as a freshman what's up
mellow with santa maybe he's like go
back and watch his sophomore taping
you're gonna love him again it's great
yeah but that's not his junior team it's
very bizarre to me especially for a team
that the players around him got better
they didn't get worse
i don't know 36 tell me if you've heard
this before dave gettleman takes a
linebacker and it's for the new york
giants that's malik harrison out of ohio
state i think i've even been a little
quiet on malik harrison but i think he's
a really solid player and i think the
linebackers are looking for those above
average starters
across the defense they need more help
at corner they need more help as pass
rushers and off ball linebackers yeah
and you've seen a little bit of a run
there in the first round you know
obviously kenneth murray's gone patrick
queen is gone i like those guys a lot
and i think i like harrison enough so i
think for this trying to project where
dave gettleman goes this is probably the
pick that makes the most sense it is so
dave gettleman to go this route number
37 la chargers we gave them justin
herbert in the first round well let's
protect him something it felt like they
never did what phillip rivers was
prioritize the offensive tackle position
in the nfl draft we're gonna give them
austin jackson here
everyone's gonna say oh the iowa game i
know ajf has to have two sacks on him
that's why he's in the first round
jackson's in the second but jackson is
an athlete the way that he moves the
replacement with his hands the footwork
is absolutely there and he is another
young guy who i think the sky is still
the limit for him so the chargers get
their quarterback now they get their
left tackle yeah we've seen
developmental tackles going round two
over and over every year some pan out
some don't that's why they're going in
round two you're taking a higher risk so
you're looking back at it now 38 the
carolina panthers they are back on the
clock here i'm going to go with zac bond
from wisconsin this guy does a lot of
different things he can rush the passer
he can play off the ball he obviously
can cover in space i think he moves a
lot better than i originally saw so i
think for bond once again if you're the
panthers the kiklee retirement is a
little bit surprising and now you do
have a hole in that front seven that you
need to fix where you need to get
younger at that position i just like all
the different roles bond and shown he
can handle i think with bond you have
people asking well
what's is he a you know master of all
trades
but doesn't do like one great thing you
know it says izzy hassan radick over
again basically or is he anthony barr
and i think that's the question in terms
of play style i know it's physicality
spectrum right a lot different yes
number 39 the miami dolphins yes they're
up again they have a lot of picks in
this draft guys we've given them a
quarterback an edge and an offensive
tackle well it's time to go running back
and i know a lot of dolphins fans get
mad at me when i go running back and
round once i wouldn't be surprised if
they do that but the first running back
comes off the board here for us deandre
swift from georgia i know he was down
this year but when he's on i mean it's
christian mccaffrey as you've said it's
alvin kamara who's my comp for him he is
special as a runner and a receiver great
dude really really fun to talk to i've
got the pleasure to know him over the
last season
he's tough i mean the shoulder injury he
tried to play through that thing when he
shouldn't have been on the field so john
dre swift to miami no more ryan
fitzpatrick leading this team in rushing
no please no swift is i mean instant
fantasy superstar i think down there in
miami we helped out them a little bit on
the offensive line there in round one as
well so when you're looking at this fit
it really does add up and i think he's a
top 15 player in this class so for him
to go at 39 exceptional exceptional if
you're a miami fan and dolphin stable is
right next to us we're not catering to
them because no one's no one knows yet
so i swear we're not doing that 40 the
cardinals skill player skill player
skill player i know they're tied up with
the david johnson contract it is what it
is i know they traded for kenyon drake
and got some production out of him
jk dobbins is still on the board here
matt here's your running back for the
next six to eight years when you look at
what dobbins does he's good in pass
protection he's good as a pass catcher
he has elite vision he can run inside
outside
if you have this guy in cliff
kingsbury's offense with jerry judy out
there threatening at wide receiver fair
not bad especially out good kyler murray
was this year right and a lot of people
are going to clap back and say why not
offensive line we just don't know how
they value
offensive line like the board right now
i can tell you right now we're not going
to have an offensive line go for over 10
more picks right now right so it makes
it it makes it difficult to be like ah
well where take which offensive lineman
and i think that's the my biggest
complaint mike drafts people are like no
we need this well there's not one
sometimes you want things for christmas
that you don't get from santa claus so
tough [ __ ]
tell him about that 41 the cleveland
browns uh
a team that we went offensive tackle
round one joe schober unless with andrew
barry now the gm unless there's a change
here i think joe schobert's gone me too
slimbacker core needs a lot of help and
i'm gonna give them one here in jordan
brooks from texas tech he's athletic
he's versatile i think he can play
middle linebacker you can play weak side
linebacker
whatever your imagination is for the
linebacker position jordan brooks could
hold it down another guy who a little
banged up so we didn't get to see him uh
at the senior bowl but he was in mobile
got a chance to meet him at the airport
seems like a great kid well it's great
for him to go down there and still meet
with teams there's a lot of interviews
there's a lot of value that i believe
brandon jones did the same i want to say
so it's really good to see those guys
make the effort and get down there 42
jacksonville jaguars are back in the
clock they had two first round picks and
now they're gonna get some speed on the
offensive side of the ball here i know
obviously giving them a speedy
linebacker and helping on the offensive
line was a need in the first round
this to me is very similar to the
hollywood brown pick where kj hamler and
that's who the pick is might not have
1200 yards next year as a rookie in that
offense but you need someone and thomas
dimitrov explained this to us very keeps
the defense back on their heels
threatens opens up the run game helps
out the quarterback i think hamlet has
wheels for days right here and
jacksonville needs a guy like that 42
that's really good value and a lot of
people might wonder about corner it's
kind of the same spot where we're in
where there's just not having here
that's a great value here yeah number 43
the chicago bears making their first
pick another team yes would have loved
to go offensive tackle here guys i'm
sorry there's not one we're not going to
have an offensive attack will come off
the board until pick 58. so it'd be a
pretty big reach another position the
bears desperately need is tight end cole
comet can block he can run up the seam
he's a very good athlete kolka matt is
the really the total picture what you
want to tie in we talked to brian kelly
about him last week and that's what he
said you know we believe that he was
going to be the first titan drafted uh
maybe if he'd gone back that might be in
the first round or a lock in the first
round but big big fan of what comet does
also a great closer if the cubs need one
i was gonna say it's not you could
always go back to baseball right really
wants to i think when you look at commit
you know brian kelly made a great point
is that the value of the inline tight
end is is back and it's furious right
now yeah look at the super bowl right
now the two starring tight ends are
great blockers right and they're the two
best tight ends in football right so
there you go i i've wow that's that's a
fall for comment we've had him in the
first round a lot good for the bears
right there somebody's got to fall i say
it all the time 44 the colts are back on
the clock here and i think they need
some size at wide receiver donovan
people's jones you're going to see this
guy at the combine test like a first
round wide receiver the production is
not there and if you watch shea
patterson during senior bowl week you
understand why because there was a
couple times where i almost got hit with
a football from him the last day of
practice indoors so i i don't mean to
pile on shea i know it upset some people
especially this guy next to me has
gotten the brunt of it man it's i'm not
doing that but i have to explain
why when i put donovan people's jones to
colts fans at 44 and they google him and
see that he didn't even have 500 yards
this year they go what the hell are you
doing that's why this player is
extremely talented he will be a better
nfl player at the next level and i think
with the colts they got jordan love now
you have donovan people's jones you're
building something out there campbell
yeah it's speed and size that's what you
need right now
uh oh yeah the shea patterson stuff it
was a rough weekend for me uh with some
some family members and dms and things
like that it's part of the job it's what
comes with the platform but
you have donovan people's jones street
black niko collins and reggie ball
and you couldn't couldn't win and the
offensive line was not terrible right no
it wasn't i mean we're going to tucson's
going to get drafted we're going to talk
about ruiz these are rules right yeah it
wasn't bad all right maybe it's jim
harbaugh i don't know 45 of tampa
buccaneers we give them a quarterback in
round one you took jason jacob eason
safety's a big need an obvious need i
mean we've talked about how much todd
wants the safety position how many of
them ashton davis who another guy
unfortunately got hurt we didn't see him
in mobile but he has coverage skills
over the top really good range great
story former walk-on he's a track guy
who's going to run in the high four
threes or low four fours a great story
and really a hell of a player yeah down
at the senior role i got to meet with
the guys at tracking football that do a
lot of correlation between high school
athletes going into college at the next
level or even just their overall their
track numbers and how it correlates and
i think for ashton that's going to be
something really important for him is
that this guy's explosive at the safety
position he might have been a late
bloomer he gets to call he's on the
track team he goes i'm going to go play
football walks on red shirts play
special teams plays a little corner and
then turns into a very very high level
safety so
i think his skill set is very very
unique 46 the denver broncos i'm going
with justin mattipuque here from texas a
m yeah this you were on this guy very
very early i've gotten to see more and
more of him because he did declare early
he wasn't necessarily guaranteed to be
in this draft and i think when he
declared you know a m played a lot of
good a m had the hardest schedule in
college football
so i felt like every time i turned on
the tv they were playing a top five team
so mata bouquet has film against very
very good teams and i thought he was a
really good player for them this year a
player they'd probably like to have back
and i think for the broncos just adding
such a great player for the interior of
their defensive line here is it's an
easy ad it's a really good pick i like
it a lot number 47 the atlanta falcons
we had them go with an edge rusher in
the first round here we're gonna go
offense and something that i don't know
if a lot of people are paying attention
to devonta freeman is getting old and
that contract is interesting there were
rumors that he was gonna be traded last
summer as well so i don't know that he
is
long for that team and they can draft
basically his mirror image and clyde
edwards elaire who i think runs with a
little more power he's a bowling ball
he'll bounce off defenders he catches
the ball exceptionally well his first
step quickness is exceptional so i know
watching him throughout the season he
was another guy like man is he going to
declare is he going to declare after the
performance he had through the stretch
run you know from like week 10 on just
felt like there might not have been many
running backs at college football who
were better than him no i'm with you
there completely all right 48 the new
york jets now before they freak out this
comes with a caveat the board's falling
a little weird you got caleb on chasing
in the first round they're going to be
aggressive for an offensive tackle
they're gonna have to upgrade this unit
in free agency
matt i just don't really have an
offensive lineman here
that is this plug and play high impact
player where you're sitting there and
going we have to take an offensive
lineman so for the jets we're gonna
double up at edge pass rush they're
going caleb on chase i'm okay with that
and bradley and i here boom boom
something you haven't had since jonathan
hit jonathan abraham
you look at this you know you look at
this group here with an i and chase on
that is speed that is power these guys
have counter moves the jets need to
figure out the offensive line they've
got to find a way to do no tackle here
there's no tackle here and they need to
also figure out edge pass rush because
they can't get after the quarterback if
you have chase on quinn and williams and
anae as your front right there that's a
team that's going to make a lot of noise
on the defensive side of the ball it's
just going to take a creative plan of
how you also solve the trenches for sam
different regime but we've seen them
attack before with this you know totally
adam's marcus mann the same draft and
again with corner just there wasn't a
corner and this was your pick but there
wasn't a corner here that i absolutely
loved there wasn't definitely wasn't a
tackle here so the only tackle i
considered is isaiah wilson from georgia
but do you think chuma adoga's are right
not to make this a jets podcast but it
doesn't feel like chuma can be the right
tackle they think he is so yeah to put
it right there
just to make that clear with jets fans
like they're looking for their left
tackle of the future and the interior
offensive line yeah but they feel very
good for whatever i don't they feel very
good about chew my right tackle for the
future yeah well i think free agency
they're gonna have a lot of money to
spend so they can definitely add there
number well that's it we get to take a
break a little break and then we'll
finish this thing out with the steelers
at pick 49.
the pittsburgh steelers are on the clock
team that did not have a first round
pick which is is weird for pittsburgh uh
the trade for minka fitzpatrick worked
out i think it worked out okay but
they're coming up on the board here and
i'll tell you man i uh this might bite
me in the ass i'm not a james connor guy
i just feel like he had that one good
year he's been banged up and exactly
he's been banged up and also you start
to worry about a guy who's now this is
the this will be year four and his
contract is gonna make for agent after
this coming season i'm gonna running
back here jonathan taylor i know he had
a shitload of carriers in college it's
okay you rent him for four years and
then if he's still good you franchise
tag them for a year and then you draft
someone else this is a short-term plan
at running back which is i think the way
to go now six years is the longest i'm
keeping a running back on my team with
franchise tags and creative ways to to
you know keep them around but with
jonathan taylor you know what you're
getting a 4-4 speed power vision yes a
lot of carries yes fumbles are a concern
that's why he falls i i think some
people see this as a fall i don't
personally that's why he's here at 49.
jt is the perfect steeler here he's
going to run a lot better than people
expect he's probably gonna be a four
four four three eight forty guy great
power he can catch the ball he could do
so many different things and for the
steelers offense getting that bell cow
kind of back in him i mean at 49 you're
getting jonathan taylor a guy that's
been a phenomenal college player on the
heisman ballot the last couple years
that's a slam dunk for me all right 50
the chicago bears this is where we're
going to go interior offensive line for
them here and this is cesar ruiz from
michigan
i think he could play across the
offensive line center guard a lot of
different things for them listen the
bears they're aging at offensive line
they're banged up at offensive line
quarterback is going to be a very hot
topic for them but there's no secret
that they have to improve this group if
they want the offense to improve as a
whole yeah kyle long's retirement or
taking taking a break his body right yep
yep understand it number 51 the dallas
cowboys we got corner and round one huge
need and again with free agency it's
going to really shape this team but for
now i'm going with an interior defensive
lineman neville gallimar from oklahoma
very very good three technique prospect
has incredible quickness coming off the
line of scrimmage i think dallas needs
that you obviously have tank lawrence
who's a good player they've missed on
tristan hill in the defensive line
didn't look good this year never became
the guy and he was a coach's pick in
round two or excuse me around two or
three it slipped my mind which one that
was round two new regime coming in
they're gonna do things differently i
think with mike mccarthy he's gonna
understand that you gotta be able to get
after the quarterback in this division
and gallimore is gonna help do that rams
at 52 just like the bears at 50. they
need to go offensive line i'm going with
tyler biotis from wisconsin another
player that can play all over the
offensive line for the rams and and this
is a team that up front matt they just
got punched in the mouth this year and
if you have jared goff as your
quarterback you just can't let that
happen you need to give him time you
need mcveigh's offense to be given time
they need to run the ball they need to
establish play action it's just the pass
protection was not very good this year
and once again the rams you have very
limited traffic capital you've got to
make it count and be oddish with his
playtime experience he could step on the
field right away next year yeah no first
round picks they got to nail it right
with their
day two and three picks to have seven of
them the eagles at 53 this is where
another corner is going to come off the
board jalen johnson is a player that i
do like he's been banged up i think
that's the biggest question with him uh
how is he going to run at the combine
but just watching tape and that is a
loaded utah defense so you do wonder a
little bit like how much is he protected
by the great players in front of him but
i i am a jalen johnson fan i wouldn't be
shocked if he floats up the board after
the combine but i could also see him not
running well and come back down a little
bit for the eagles they have to start
getting younger in the secondary and
looking for some playmakers at corner i
think johnson he fits what they're doing
there defensively yeah i thought him and
bradley and i were the standout players
from that utah defense that had a lot of
senior bowl invites a lot of publicity
and honestly a really really good season
here so 54 the buffalo bills are back on
the clock and they're getting an edge
pass rush help you mentioned it before
the show shaq lawson is expected to hit
free agency we'll see if they're able to
retain him i'm going to go with tara
lewis here from alabama guy that did
look very good at the senior bowl
practices this week
honestly he really can do it all i think
for lewis he's somebody that we've
talked about on these mock drafts a lot
he's coming on late you know as the
season goes on he could even be a top 40
pick this is a little bit of a fall for
him but lewis can get after the
quarterback i think he could play the
run could do a lot of different things
and the bills have that need in the
front seven playing next to ed oliver i
think for lewis the only question is
their health it always because
two knee surgeries that we know of at
alabama that's going to be the biggest
question number 55 the falcons we've
given them an edge and a running back
well austin hooper their star tight end
is a free agent so i'm gonna free excuse
me so i'm gonna tie it in here bryson
hopkins from purdue talk about a good
senior bowl week this dude had a good
senior bull week showing that he can be
an inline tight end but he has quickness
he can flex out a little bit he's a good
blocker he works very well up the seam
has a huge catch radius if it were not
for cole comet he would be the runaway
tied in one for me in this class i've
loved him all year long so hopkins to
the falcons here to start over that
tight end position yeah comment kind of
crash hopkins party as ty did one it's
it's tough for him 56 the miami dolphins
i mean we've given them so many
different players see we've solved the
edge somebody said vanessa to
otagonvilloa at quarterback
i believe deandre swift at running back
so i'm going to look at corner which is
also a little bit of a need for them
there and i'm going to give this name a
shot here auburn's noah igbonogony you
nailed it listen i saw you tweeting
about this guy the other day i know he's
a really good athlete he probably is
going to play the slot a lot at the next
level
he's somebody that played very very well
this year for an auburn defense we talk
about derek brown marlin davidson nico
all those good players up front well
this was the guy at corner and for the
miami dolphins i know they have xavier
howard there but they're not done yet on
the second area he's battle tested
coming out of the sec the knock on him
was going to be ball skills he didn't
have an interception this past year but
he did play a lot he did knock a lot of
passes down he had 18 points
i'm fine with that absolutely fine with
that 57 the houston texans their first
pick after trading for laramie tunsil
again this could go a million ways but i
went edge rusher here julian ogura who
might have been a first round guy where
not for a late injury but okora is just
a producer he like like brian kelly said
he could dip he can bend he has speed
great traits not always a well-rounded
player i think he's going to have to get
stronger he's going to have to get a
little bit smarter but he can beat you
with his speed off the edge they've
locked up whitney merciless they
obviously have a charleston mini hue
who's up and coming you have jj watt
this could put this defense back to what
it was when they had jadavian clowney
yeah that front seven i mean they make
noise they really do and i do like that
you brought up just the extensions and
what being healthy and then also they
capitalized off of the uh seattle trade
for with jacob martin jacob martin had a
couple nice pass rush reps much better
than we expected yeah we were like who
when he got traded so 58 the minnesota
vikings are back on the clock here and
this is where we're going to go back to
offensive line here isaiah wilson from
georgia offensive tackle the vikings
they load up on it feels like they take
an offensive lineman each year that
garrett bradbury we saw had a really
nice postseason i think he struggled
early on but he's going to be their
center of the future so for the vikings
dalvin cook a marvelous year gary kuback
is stepping into the full-time offensive
coordinator role which is phenomenal for
them and he'll be looking for some dogs
up front literally from georgia
isaiah wilson yeah i i like isaiah
wilson uh a little bit of a surprise
that he came out early
georgia losing three offensive tackles
two to the draft one of the transfer
portals so big changes for the dogs
coming there number 59 the seattle
seahawks uh gave him a d-lineman and
marlon davidson a player we both love
staying in the sec here they need to get
size at corner which is what they love
we're going travon digs from alabama
here i could see seattle going a lot of
directions whether that's offensive line
another wide receiver but with digs on
the board it's just too sweet to pass
upon a guy who sticks to 200 pounds and
can break your collarbone when he
presses you at the line of scrimmage
who's still getting better mellow talks
about it all the time you know he was a
receiver not that long ago he's still
getting better at corner and if there's
anything we've learned from john
schneider drafts and they still have
guys like scott fitter or there trent
kirchner is right this is kind of the
position this an edge they load up on
time and time again they'll use valuable
draft assets to stack the deck at that
position 60 the baltimore ravens i still
think they need one more wide receiver
here i'm going with michael pittman from
usc had a really nice week down and
mobile had a phenomenal senior season
i think when you go back and look what
he did against utah he showed that he
can win down the field the ravens look
for speed but this guy's also a
big-bodied player that can help in their
run-heavy blocking offense and he's an
interesting player because i think there
are going to be a lot of questions about
how fast is he and throughout senior
bowl week i'll be honest there were
times where i didn't love israel running
but then you would watch him catch the
ball and be like okay well i like that
about you a lot and so i think that
there are some areas where he can
definitely improve but he's coming in
here ready to rock and roll and gives
him something they don't have in that
physical wide receiver number 61 the
tennessee titans went d-line in round
one with ross blacklock jack conklin
they bet on jack conklin being a free
agent they did not pick up the fifth
year tinder well now he's about to get
paid he's probably one of the five or
six best free agents on the market they
cannot pay everyone so there's a good
chance that they have to let him go matt
pert from uconn i think could be a very
very solid right tackle especially if
they keep up this run first offensive
strategy though we've seen them deploy
the last really one and a half seasons
with a lot of success so matt per a name
we've not talked about a lot on this
podcast but no we have no good powerful
offensive tackle who fits well in the
run game 62 the green bay packers we got
them leviskus chanel in the first round
help a wide receiver devonta adams i
think the jimmy graham days are coming
to an end we're gonna go with hunter
bryant here who's really a big wide
receiver for washington but if you're
looking for a seam weapon a guy that's a
really good athlete he'll test very well
he could do a lot after the catch this
is the packers just hey aaron rodgers is
getting older let's load this up with
weapons we know we have devonta adams
and aaron jones those guys are great but
he still needs more someone to stretch
the field keep safety's out of the box
yeah and get across the first down
marker not behind it someone who could
catch the ball in the middle of the
field would be great number 63 the
kansas city chiefs again not a
prediction just based on win loss
records they we went corner early this
is a team they have a lot of needs and
not many draft picks they have five
draft picks so i do expect them to trade
back from 31 or 32 overall to get more
here they have to go interior offensive
line that has been a big weakness for
them uh laverne
duvernay tardif there we go is a free
agent this year they do not expect him
to be back just because of salary cap
limitations so getting an interior
offensive lineman will be huge matt
hennessey from temple go play center can
play guard i think he's perfect for that
inside zone rush scheme he's quick he's
nasty and most importantly for andy reid
he is smart you have to be smart to come
and play as a rookie for andy yeah i
like that pick a lot for the chiefs 64
to round out this two-round mock draft
seattle is back on the clock and we're
gonna go offensive line here with lucas
niang from tcu this is a little bit of a
developmental tackle i think seattle is
a team that has no problem betting on
athletes time and time again and i think
with niang i don't think he's ready to
be on the field next year right away i
think there's some pass protection
questions and with these tcu guys it
feels like they play a little lighter
than most offensive linemen at times but
for seattle you need to start buying
stocks on offensive linemen you can't go
into each year and say well this is what
we got russ and run for your life you
really need to start thinking about the
latter half of russ's career you know
we've seen quarterbacks we've seen a
team like you know matt stafford has
dealt with injuries a lot of guys have
dealt with injuries you got to keep russ
healthy keep them upright and that's the
explanation for niang here yeah a guy
who didn't give up a sack in three years
as a starter very impressive and it is
the big 12. so i'll add that in but
still a good player all right that is
our show for today tomorrow we'll be
back recording another one so you'll get
a show tuesday afternoon slash wednesday
morning thursday morning friday morning
and then monday morning that's right is
that the plan yeah you had it right i
think if you don't just keep hitting
that download yeah subscribe subscribe
if you subscribe to stick to football
you don't have to worry about this and
subscribe to the bleacher report youtube
channel so every time we upload a new
episode you get to watch it not do your
work you get distracted with the bosses
yeah
please just push play on all those
episodes once they download and yeah and
we can keep you company at work that is
our show for connor's matt we'll talk to
y'all tomorrow